Narrator: FOAM DARTS ARE
USUALLY PRETTY HARMLESS,
BUT NOT IN THE HANDS
OF A MASTER OF DISASTER.
♪♪
WHOA!
BOOM!
TAKE THAT, CAN.
Narrator:
WITH OVER 8 MILLION HITS,
THIS IS THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
FOAM-DART GUN EVER.
♪♪
LET'S DART OVER
TO ALASSIO, ITALY,
TO MEET GIACO, THE CREATOR
OF THIS DEADLY DART GUN.
ME AND A BUNCH OF FRIENDS
WERE JOKING ABOUT, LIKE,
HOW FAST CAN A DART GO,
AND I WAS ACTUALLY THE ONE
IN THE CORNER,
LIKE, REALLY SERIOUSLY THINKING
ABOUT TESTING IT.
THE FIRST TIME I SHOT IT
WAS WAY MORE POWERFUL
THAN I EXPECTED, ACTUALLY.
I NEVER FOUND THE DART ANYWHERE.
I THINK IT EXPLODED SOMEWHERE.
Narrator: HOW'S GIACO'S CANNON
CAUSING CHAOS?
THE DART EXITS THE GUN AT AN
ASTONISHING 1,800 MILES PER HOUR
OR 2,900 KILOMETERS PER HOUR.
THAT'S TWICE THE SPEED OF SOUND.
Pampena: EVEN THOUGH THE DART
IS VERY LIGHT,
TRAVELING AT SUCH A HIGH SPEED
MEANS IT HAS
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF ENERGY --
340 JOULES.
THAT HAPPENS TO BE A QUARTER
THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY
OF A RIFLE SHOT.
Giaco: THIS IS MY CANNON.
THE POWER COMES
FROM COMPRESSED AIR
THAT I STORE IN THIS TANK.
THEN I PUT MY DART IN IT.
WHEN I'M READY,
I PRESS THE BOTTOM, AND...
THE MAGIC HAPPENS.
3, 2, 1.
♪♪
TO GET THESE DARTS UP TO SPEED,
GIACO IS USING THE POWER
OF A REPURPOSED OXYGEN TANK,
WHICH HAS GAS PRESSURIZED
AT 400 POUNDS PER SQUARE INCH,
WHICH IS 27 TIMES THE PRESSURE
OF NORMAL AIR.
WHEN GIACO OPENS THE VALVE,
THE HIGH-PRESSURE AIR
INSIDE THE TANK
WANTS TO EQUALIZE WITH
THE LOWER-PRESSURE AIR OUTSIDE,
AND THE ONLY WAY IT CAN DO THAT
IS PUSH THE DART OUT
AND KEEP ON MOVING.
♪♪
I THINK THERE'S
REALLY SATISFYING
ABOUT DESTROYING THINGS.
AND I GUESS DOING WITH A TOY
THAT'S MEANT FOR KIDS,
IT'S EVEN MORE INTERESTING.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: FOR BUILDING
A FOAM-DART CANNON
THAT'S DEFINITELY
NOT CHILD'S PLAY,
GIACO,
YOU'RE A MASTER OF DISASTER.